[Music]
the male orgasm is an explosive affair
well the female orgasm happens behind
closed curtains so what do we know about
it well of 8,000 nerve endings the
clitoris is definitely the star of the
show
no wonder up to 70% of women require
direct clitoral stimulation to achieve
orgasm yet it's not all about the
clitoris
in one study 20% of women reported
having orgasms just from kissing or
performing oral sex on someone else
orgasms can even sneak up from behind 94
percent of women who had anal sex said
they were able to climax a lucky 10% of
people have experienced orgasm through
exercise of those 51 percent say it was
abdominal exercise but did it
what about purely vaginal orgasms kind
of a MIT research shows that they
resonate from the clitoris vagina and
uterus all working together these three
things make up the mythical g-spot great
teamwork body but what goes on in her
brain after the big moment oxytocin
prolactin and endorphins are released
creating that nice relaxed feeling
however at the same time dopamine levels
in the brain drop while prolactin levels
increase this drop can help the brain
from wanting sex to the detriment of
other necessary activities even more
fascinating a woman's pain thresholds
can increase up to 107 percent during
orgasm which may be linked to
alleviating pain during childbirth and
orgasms do occasionally occur during
childbirth
but only 0.3% of the time a less
stressful way of getting off is to join
the 53% of American women who have used
a vibrator so now you know a little more
about female orgasms that great
mysterious journey to the top of love
Mountain now go put your knowledge to
use alone or with a friends
[Music]
oh and why not subscribe to wire